yeah what did your parents do Davis do
the preacher if you didn't listen oh you
know what that's his character hitched
right a pagan god for no money
Korean missionaries were the reason why
he had an education in Korea so that's
how it happened oh I've got you are you
a Christian
yes okay I'm sorry for saying that
that's okay no no no I want to retake
what there's he's not paid he was but I
don't want to yeah but even the Lord
Jesus Christ died for your sins yes I do
you do can we talk about this for a
second yeah do you mind oh no go ahead
because he listen I'm going to say this
right up front
uh-huh I like you I do once I saw you I
like this guy okay I feel like we can
have a relationship okay
definitely pounds like if I saw you in a
club we pound it that's all I want but I
want to ask you this so see you believe
do you believe this that if I masturbate
that's lusting and therefore that's the
same thing as rape in the Bible no baby
no because Christians believe that
lusting is the same thing as having sex
or whatever right yes this one of you
yeah it's that they're both on the same
in God's eyes they're both the same
thing if I masturbate so do you believe
that no okay do you believe that
masturbating is a sin no I think it's
the reason why people don't kill each
other okay well you're not a Christian
then I mean I know you're not I mean
okay you paint it you paint all
Christians would see you Brian
in a woman's right to choose yes he
associate all Christians with a very
very like every church in LA with the
rock band and the music that culture
yeah the Mojave what's that call are you
talking about Old Testament mosaic what
the cause a mosaic I got my hobby okay
because the Christians I'm used to or
the Protestant born-again right all
right well then that's it you speak in
tongues no what did that's that's all
that's what I was my dad did that should
used to creep me the [ __ ] out okay
you really did a dinner speak in tongue
I don't know if it was speaking in
tongue I just know I mean he was at
night and he was like maybe it was an
English English Korean thing that he was
doing he could have been combination
between do two lanes but I just know
that there were scandals and he so you
wake up in the middle not really do that
I thought my dad was possessed because
he wouldn't explain to me what it is and
I would go to the bathroom I would get
I'd ask my mom I'll say yeah yeah yeah
and he's speaking in tongues yeah and
then I thought my mom do it and it
freaked me out with ya know my mom I
don't think she was doing it though yeah
I think she was just all about survival
too because when I first came here to
the Philippines we the reason my sister
and I came here from the Philippines
were that we were able to afford it is
because a a Nigerian church had like
picked my dad up and basically from
being like homeless and they raised
enough to church and I guarantee raised
money to buy my mom my sister and my
plane ticket to come to America so as a
thank you my dad was like you have to go
we have to go to church right and every
Sunday we would go all the way to some
like on Normandy it was like an
all-black Church these people were so
[ __ ] nice but they had this moment
where they did testimonials and they
would speak in tongues they would
collapse they would you know it was just
a real theatrical you know time
and because my sister and I were so
thankful for them helping us we faked
that [ __ ] my sister went to like fake
convulsions and [ __ ] she's like rolled
her eyes because my dad was like these
[ __ ] people saved your life [ __ ]
game on [ __ ] like [ __ ] perv all rise
wrong eyes I genuinely believe when I
see that's why that [ __ ] used to always
make me feel weird as a kid yeah like
suddenly you go to a church for like a
couple months and then I wasn't you
speak 14 languages you speak
[ __ ] out here man yeah so I didn't
really like that part of it
[Music]